no ma il premio pac in the whip vj e
canto happy to play your game
chissenefrega nell'intero tanto non
parlo inglese non lo parlo l'inglese vai
avanti che devo fare entro o eccolo
eccolo lordi oggi che bella vita che
faccio bella tutti ragazzi venuti a
questo nuovo io sono per i generi siamo
sul nord birri cloud
non so neanche se pronunciato una
lettera giusta di quello che ho detto ma
vabbè permesso allora foreste aspettare
le spetta foreste foresta spettrale the
night before del festival
allora è una mano un po strano ha una
grafica stranissima però a voce è
giocata una roba così simile a quello di
babbo natale lo ricordate vabbè ciò
crystal oppure se i kristol visto che
non è una quella di segue non hai la
canottiera hai solo il pezzo di sopra
kristol stiamo andando non so dove
stiamo andando ragazzi certamente però
mi piace che partono gli horror così
senza troppo senso camping lotto 1 o
kristol stai fermo dice che mi mette
ansia mette psa lui che mi ricorda
addosso i mostri sto gioco va beh ti
puoi stare calmo calmo stai calmo calmo
se una tipa ma ti chiami che visto
quindi per me non sei voti va bene non
ho ben capito lo dobbiamo andare persona
lanterna con la prendiamo cristo s'è
aperta ora kakà mima seguimi fai qua
siamo nell'industria da dentro io
cagasotto sei venuto solo per seguirmi e
farmi cagare addosso lo so io se mi
spunti mentre cerco le cose ti ammazzo
permesso videocassette e lattine tutto
cioè estintore mio zio dirigente
quantità
che è successo
questo cristo sento una musica orribile
non mi piace ragazzi e successo a caso
il bo sono entrato in una porta musica
da horror però non ci rinuncerà niente
va bene ma hanno un'altra che melo no le
cose per aprirla cosa mi metto i
cancelli ma sto gioco non si chiamava la
suora qualcosa eccolo ma l'inizio eccolo
il tagliaunghie porca vacca mannaia cm
sei anni a trovarla bene cielo ho preso
in prestito un tagliaunghie mi servivano
è permesso
però c'è un tizio sotto il tavolo salve
ci sono dei pezzi di gamba mi mi fa
piacere
non mi interessa anzi io uscirei anche
volentieri molto molto molto simpatico
cristo alti ricordavo più sexy va tutto
bene tutto giusto amo il mio lavoro non
mi ha lavorando mio lavoro
amo il mio no dai è veramente maledetto
crystal non è una bellezza si chiama
così lui veramente ma da amica tutto da
capo
lo lascio vado direttamente al punto ma
vado direttamente nel punto più le
cesoie torno indietro ecco c'è qualcosa
che tocca di cesa gli sono amico dove
sono figurati
dov'era il bagno eccolo ma come ce l'ho
già
carlo reader devo devo prendere non ci
sono le cesoie erano qua
porca vacca morta che brutto erano quale
cesoie ci sono nove erano veramente per
tutti
porca vacca quanto ansiolitico sto gioco
ma veramente mi chiedo vabbè giuro che
non ci sono più le cesoie non solo perse
piano andiamo direttamente al punto dove
sono le mie cesoie
dove sono le mie cesoie dove tua sorella
dove chi mi interessa particolarmente
dove le cesoie le ho perse cristo al non
si vede più bidibi bodibi bu non faceva
rima però senza mai a morte via chiudi
chigi la prima è mica le porte con tanta
facilità le apre le apre la preda pre
velocissimo anche veloce come la vita
niente barbato onna ma che a ansia no
maraga veramente la porta non si apriva
più buono a sapersi
raga non ci sono più le cesoie ma serio
possono sfornate da un'altra parte qua
ma non ci sono più
la chiave la key card
ho trovato la key card cioè la chiave è
quella per aprire la porta strana va
bene ma ben capito cosa serve prova chi
se ne frega le cesoie andiamo avanti
eccola ma non devo prima mentre
l'accordo va a cena della corrente che
mi serve fusibile che non ho perché non
ho le cesoie qui ti ammazzo la sorella
pagano non capito c'è veramente
ma ce l'hanno in mano lo sbaglio in mano
a qualcosa non ho capito cosa va bene
[Musica]
maya anche nella vasca da bagno non
pensavo aiuto
è veramente una vita difficile e gli
aerei e marianna hai rotto i tre quarti
è diventato un raise game non horror si
sia sempre perché quel tipo inquieto
abbastanza ma il fusibile ma vero spesso
e alla mia niente stato mancanza
percezione quindi non serve a niente
sarò mi mancano allora la key card
ma non c'è la chicca o amica regala
veramente riuscito dvd ammazzo vitry
turo tutti ma ho trovato il fusibile e
non c'è la chioccia e una cosa ce n'è
un'altra ma non ci sono mai tutte
insieme vabbè cesoie
eccole cielo sono resistere medico fu
simile fusibile dai perfetto key card
trovata sola morte di giulia porta ok
sono uscito sono uscito sono forte io
sono un giocatore vero meli merito si
iscritti grazie a tutti bene bene via
via via dove è andato cristo ma che ne
so io spero che stati stia bene non è un
tipo sì a cristo
va bene va bene così sono forte io mamma
mia che giocatore perfetto che ansia di
vivere la vita perché vediamo su
festival so sorride festival è stato
cancellato tua sorella
perfetto allora devo trovare la macchina
di crystal di cristo spero non sia
questa sarà questa accesa kristol dimmi
te se quello lì deve andare a
nascondersi monnet dove nei nomi nei
momenti sbagliati che cambia idea di di
vita amico mino cioè mi segue e mi seguì
sempre o non mi seguì mai non è che mi
segue poi cambi idea una certa dunque
non è possibile che se mi servono le
chiavi tua cosa illuminato da farmi city
eccolo cristo
cristo cristo
no cristo che cosa ti è successo ma no
madama ma no mandavano si fa comunque li
dovrebbe risorgere tra un po che tre
giorni fa è comunque io posso spostarmi
da quasi spostiamoci mi dispiace cristo
supremo della tua torcia non si scarica
la mia in casinò e alla missione le
chiavi però specie che le chiavi della
macchina eccole qua non ho mica vis
grazie via via via veloci come questa
non si apre niente
che bella giornata l'offerta ho trovato
l'ho trovata via via via via scappa you
have escaped o vi è finito breve
skypephone avevo dire che c'è un altro
livello che ho finito proprio
[Musica]
sul serio come non era così male sto
gioco era carino dei ragazzi è finito
cioè pensavo durasse molto di dove che
sono finito è finito
no finito mi ha finito o se è finito e
fini non è che è finito per finta
no dai raga fate i serie è finito gioco
finito di una ladra morta perché non
puoi vivere una vita normale che ci sono
pure è salve salve non vi avevano visti
no è che come già visti prima quindi mi
sarei mai aspettato di rivedervi bello
possiamo avere dei titoli di coda per
cortesia si vado a giocare a the peawees
a qualsiasi altra cosa
bello questo questo nero please insert
videocassette va bene ragazzi io sono
sempre più orgoglioso del mio lavoro da
youtube e ogni volta è giocare una roba
del genere spero che vi sia piaciuto
questo era il nostro nord pur i groove
spero mi sia piaciuto ragazzi come al
solito se di ricerca sull'argomento è un
mi piace
seguitemi anche sudista granché come
individuate nella descrizione sensi
schietta e non ci giriamo a un prossimo
vita
[Musica]